the way that society's changed and you
know gone woke and so sensitive is the
ringer a movie that you see as
problematic in any way no not at all we
made that movie with the support of the
Special Olympics and they wanted us to
push the comedy and push the boundaries
I'm very proud of that movie and
unfortunately I think people heard the
synopsis that I was going to fake like
pretend to have a disability yeah so I
can the Special Olympics I think people
heard the premise and they're like oh
that's not for us but it's actually a
very uh sweet movie I've never watched a
Johnny noxo movie that I wasn't in and
then recently it uh it occurred to me I
kept the streak alive and I thought well
thank
you you shouldn't have I know but but
now I think like the ringer first up on
my Marathon yeah I I I'm really proud
it's one of my favorite films